fleury zvenigorod match retour
un dernier arrêt de la gardienne
brésilienne les panthères tiennent leur
match nul et surtout leur qualification
pour une demi-finale européenne pour que
le riz c'est incroyable en deux ans et
demi on est passé d'un statut de ne pas
descendre en d2 et l'an passé en
demi-finale de coupe d'europe
premier en championnat c'est notre
saison est partie pour tout gagner
on est fier d'elle des supporteurs aux
anges qui ont vibré avec leur équipe
durant ce long week end européen
les fleuryssoises s'étaient largement
imposés à l'aller elles abordaient ce
match retour plus sereine avec un esprit
un peu revanchard face aux russes et
surtout une belle confiance après une
série de bons résultats
ouais c'est vrai il y avait cette
dynamique de coupe de la ligue les deux
victoires après là on avait vraiment
envie de la coupe d'europe ce soit un
petit peu la revanche si de l'année
dernière c'était la même équipe à la
même étape donc une demi-finale on est
dans le carré final de la coupe d'europe
on est très content
sur ce match les russes ont été plus
menaçante mais sous la houlette de
christophe casson prenant le relais de
l'entraîneur convalescent les panthères
voulait mettre un point d'honneur à ne
pas perdre
on a fait les efforts jusqu'à la fin
parce que c'était pas ça qu'on a été
menés on arrive à égaliser à sa 10 ou 15
secondes la fin du match donc on est
contentes ça fait plaisir il fallait les
accompagner du mieux possible j'espère
avoir fait mais elles ont pris
énormément de confiance depuis le mois
de janvier donc fallait juste les
accompagner pour qu'ils puissent être en
pleine réussite ce week end la rage de
vaincre des panthères qui ont arraché ce
match nul 25 25
prochaine escale l'autriche et l'ipo
niederosterreich début avril